就是我看老友记，
我跟他家讲我的心路历程好不好？
我刚开始的时候特别喜欢Rachel，
因为她长得好看啊，
时尚啊，
她的穿衣风格几乎影响了我整个青春时代。
就是刚开始的时候喜欢rach秋，
就是因为她漂亮、
幽默、
时尚，
对自己的工作也挺上心的，
也挺专注的。
我特别喜欢rich秋，
后来看第二遍、
第三遍的时候又喜欢莫妮卡，
我觉得莫妮卡内心强大，
愿意照顾别人，
他虽然有点强迫症，
他是爱干净，
他自己的工作他也干得很好，
他恋爱他也谈得很好，
慢慢的觉得他是所有人当中最成熟的那一个。
然后我就喜欢莫妮卡，
看到七八遍的时候也就喜欢菲比，
我觉得菲比她原生家庭这么不好的情况下，
她还能成长为这样一个完全有独立自我的女性，
完全接纳自己的女性，
就是她那么勇敢，
她想什么她都很直白，
她的脑回路跟大家不一样，
但她的那种可爱和洒脱，
以及不在乎别人怎么看，
不在乎别人怎么评价，
有她自己内心的一个准绳和原则的那个女性的话，
我也爱上了C比，
真的是我看了若干遍啊，
就是10遍打底老友记，
我发现我分别从Rachel mon、
妮卡和菲比身上分别攫取了一部分，
揉进了我自己的性格里，
我从他们每一个女性身上都学到了东西，
从他。
那每一个人的生命经历当中都得到了力量，
都得到了成长，
这就是一种学习。
你从每一个人身上，
你都汲取了他生命当中你非常欣赏的那个点，
揉成你自己生命的样子，
或到你生命的泥水里面，
塑造成今天你的性格，
这就是学习的过程。